in George Washington's spymaster Thomas
Allen looks at some of the covert
techniques used by General George
Washington during the Revolutionary War
this talk from imagination station in
arlington virginia is 40 minutes oh hi i
just want to talk a little tiny bit
about Georgian and maybe you'll have a
few questions first of all we know him
as our first president but he also was
the general who ran all our troops in
the revolution and before that he had
been a soldier in another war with the
French and Indian War and he learned to
be a soldier when he started to be the
commander-in-chief of all of our forces
in the revolution the first thing he
realized was that he had a small
untrained army that didn't have very
many weapons that didn't really know how
to be soldiers to well up against the
most feared army in the world the
British Army at that time was one of the
biggest armies in the world certainly
one of the best equipped and the best
trained so he had to figure a way to
even things out a little bit and he had
something going for him the first thing
he had going for him what do you think
that might be well we'll get to the
spies in a minute he had he had the the
fact that he knew the land better than
he knew the British would so he would
know where the mountains and the rivers
and the valleys were and where the roads
were and how to get from one place to
another better than they the British
would so he did have that advantage and
then the other advantage which was spies
as you said really came to him in a
it over time it wasn't something that he
deliberately did it became some an idea
that he had and he made that idea grow
so he realized that he had to have a way
to learn what was going on with the
British and he knew that the British
would be doing the same thing to him and
both sides had a big advantage which
sometimes spies don't have they both
spoke the same language they both had
the same culture I mean they both had
the same idea of how people worked so i
could be a spy for the British or I
could be a spy for the Americans it
wouldn't be any kind of disguise or
learning a language or anything I could
just say I'll be a spy and go and
volunteer to either side so there was a
complication and we see a little bit
today if anybody listen to television
they there's always a counter you know
what counter means going up against so
you have spies and then you have counter
spies so if you're sending a spy over to
my side I've got to have a way of
looking at that man or woman and
deciding whether that person is a spy
another thing and I want to tell you
about this particularly most of the way
spies talked to each other is through
secret communications of various kind
and one of the ways you can do this in
Washington wrote about this and he told
his spies exactly how to do it he said
use invisible ink I'm going to tell you
about invisible ink in a minute but what
he said was right a regular letter or
even buy a book and write on the on the
side of the book or right on one of the
blank pages of the book don't just have
a blank piece of paper be what you put
the invisible ink on
write something and right in between the
lines with invisible ink okay what's
invisible ink here's what I did to make
this I took some lemon lemon juice
regular lemon juice and i took this pan
and this happens to be an old-fashioned
kind of pen almost the kind of George
Washington would have used and I wrote a
message I let the lemon juice dry and
then I put it on this toaster over here
and i heated it and the heat brings out
the lemon and you could do that at home
with a lot of permission there weren't
any toasters around those days so they
would have used lamps or candles and I'm
very much against doing that so that's
why I use the toaster but the idea was
that I could send a regular message from
one person to another and if the British
got if the British got that message and
read it they would read a regular letter
they wouldn't see the invisible ink then
it comes to me and I heat the letter and
I and the invisible ink pops out well
that's one way to do it another way is
to use a code Washington use codes quite
a bit for two kinds of codes and one of
them is actually called a cipher and the
other is called a code took me a long
time to learn this when I was figuring
all this out and then I finally figured
out how to remember it a cipher is
something that is a substitution of a
letter or number for a letter so you can
take the alphabet A through Z and
scramble it up and as long as I know how
you scrambled it in you know how you
scramble did you can send me a message
but that's pretty easy to check here's
the way it start if you had it that kind
of a cipher you'd say I'm going to look
through that message for something that
comes up a lot let's say it's the letter
R
and I know that doesn't stop stand for
our anymore so what would be the letter
that would show up the most in a real
message any ideas most common letter
yeah II if you go through the dictionary
which you could do some day if you
wanted to have a long day of going
through this dictionary you'd find that
the letter E is the letter that used the
most in the English language and then a
on comes in there and s and there's a
whole frequency that people have figured
out so it's easy to crack a cipher of
code involves a codebook you've got to
have a way of substituting not just a
letter but if I wanted to say bookstore
I might use orange as the word for
bookstore and there's no way you're
going to figure that out unless you have
a code book or you start really working
very hard on the message so if we both
have code books then we can send each
other code messages and that's basically
what Washington used in the back of the
book is the number code that he used the
numbers there were three numbers for
various words in the code the three
numbers for Washington were 7-eleven he
was known as agent 711 that code was not
in a code book for many many years
people were looking for George
Washington's code book and nobody knew
that it wasn't really a book it was a
bunch of pages it was seven or eight
pages that were in Washington's papers
in my editor at the geographic said well
why don't we run some of the code and I
said well I we've people have only found
a small amount of the code and she went
to the library of congress and she found
the papers that had all the code on so
you can go in the back of the book and
you can see what
various words would mean in terms of
this code now there's an even better
code and this was used a couple of times
this is called a book code we're in a
bookstore so it's going to be easy for
you to remember it if two of you go and
buy the same book and then each of you
and has to be a book that has a fair
number of words in it and each one of
you has that exact same book then you
can send to each other a message that
would consist of of three sets of
numbers and that would be the first
number would be the page the second
number be the line and the third number
would be the word that's in that line
the fourth word or the fifth word in
that line so your enemy would pick up
something that had a lot of numbers on
it and the enemy would think oh well
just using a cipher I'll just look
through these and then says wait a
minute this is complicated this is a
code and I don't have a code book and I
went into that person's house and I
looked all over and I never saw any code
book I wonder how they're doing it and
what the enemy would be doing would be
looking for a code book but wouldn't be
looking for a regular book and it's that
regular book that produces a code book
and that's called a book code and the
code book is just an ordinary book so
Washington's people did that and the
British used that too it's very very
hard to track down a book code ah so
that's that's basically a lot of the
information that was being passed one
person to another both by the British to
their agents and by their agents to the
British and on our side the same thing
would all be done by a code of some kind
either a cipher or code using a code
book and and and also they would be
frequently writing
in invisible ink the good thing about
the invisible ink was that you didn't
have to remember the codes or you didn't
have to have a book you could just write
a message that no one would see but it's
no big secret how you can decipher
invisible ink invisible ink that was
used during a revolution was kind of the
kind of visible ink that i've been using
lemon anything that's an acid that would
come up on the paper when you heat it
but then Washington had a man who was a
chemist and the chemist came up with a
special kind of invisible ink in which
you use one kind of chemical to write
the message and the person getting that
message has to have a second kind of
chemical in order to read it has to take
that liquid and put it on the on the
letter at our runner or the piece of
paper that has the coded message and and
sees it and that was a there are two
chemicals and I didn't put that in the
book because I didn't want anybody
fooling around with chemicals when they
were reading the book but even if I had
put it in the book it would be a pretty
tough job because people aren't quite
sure exactly what the chemicals were
that George Washington was using and a
similar fact is there are many people
men and women who worked for George
Washington as spies and their names
still are not known sometimes you can be
a spy so well that your real name and
who you were what you did never becomes
known and there are some people it in
the book who we can't identify by their
real names well that's what I basically
know about George Washington's use of
codes and and spies but have you got
some questions you could I'll give you a
try answer on looked like you had one
well you were getting ready to pop
okay anybody all right oh my i read your
mind and i'll figure out what you may
have said what you may have been
thinking i think one of the things that
that people wonder about is how does it
feel to be a spy how does it feel to be
living two lives at the same time and
are you always wondering are you and you
get caught you're living a very
difficult life and being a spy is a
tough tough job and in those days if
either side caught someone spying you
know what happened to that person yeah
executed hanged one of the one of the
first persons who was caught as a spy in
the American Revolution Nathan Hale he
was our our man he was caught and he was
hanged and it was really the hanging of
Nathan Hale that inspired Washington to
set up a spy network that would have
more training and more the the people he
would use wood would have some idea what
it meant to be a spy Nathan Hale really
didn't have much training and he was
easily caught the British had better
counter spies than we did dress and like
a costume when they yeah oh that's a
good question uh a couple of times both
sides seem to have used some kind of
costume or disguise there was one case
where two British soldiers were told to
go spy and see where the count this is
just before the Revolutionary War
started to go off and look and see if
hick they could find out where the
rebels were going to store their
ammunition and guns so the the British
toothbrush soldiers dressed up as what
they called countrymen men who lived in
the country so they put on an old code
and old pants and a jacket but they did
something pretty stupid they brought a
servant with them
so you know countrymen didn't have
servants so they go into a tavern and
they sit down and to have lunch and the
waitress in the tavern comes along and
she was an african-american free slave
who was working in Massachusetts and she
sees the British officers with a map and
she sees their clothes and she sees this
servant and she goes to her boston says
we've got a couple of British spies out
there and they catch on to and they
realized that something's happened so
they get up and leave and they were not
really caught but there was a record
made about them and this record was was
found later by the colonists and they
were able to figure out who these two
men were and that was that was one
disguise there was also a young boy who
was we just look like a regular boy he
wasn't disguised as anything other than
a boy but he had on his coat um he had
cloth buttons these are regular buttons
that are covered with cloth which was
fashioned at the time and he would go
behind the lines a British were let him
through he's just a kid we're not going
to bother with him and he would go to
Washington's headquarters and there his
brother who was a member of the army
would take the button take the cloth off
and inside was a little tiny piece of
paper that had a coded message in it and
it was him it was a code that only the
family knew mean the two brothers knew
the code and the mother and father knew
the cone and it was not only in code but
it was hidden and it was giving
Washington's generals and officers an
idea of what was going on in
Philadelphia which if British were
holding at that time so that's a couple
of times when disguise of some kind was
used or costume
then question questions parent if it for
the kids if they like history and they
also like to ride what's the process
that you go about taking a piece of time
in history this you obviously didn't
live during and turning it into writing
about the history of that time finding
out what exactly happens oh yeah let's
see that's a good question I it when I
first started working on books it was
pretty honey you would go to a library
or we go to a place where they have what
they call archives these are pieces of
paper that went all the way back to the
time you'd be be working on and now I
can go on the web and you can too and
you can find amazing things the
University of Virginia has on the web
thousands of pages of papers that were
written by George Washington all you
have to do is go onto google say
university of virginia george washington
and you'll start to see all kinds of
papers there's another university
university of michigan which has a
special library it has to do with spine
espionage is a fancy word for it and
they have actual copies and real the
real letters that were written from one
british spy master to some of his spies
and in a couple of them if you look very
closely you can see this little yellow
sort of stain on the letters and that's
where the invisible ink was so it's
easier for me now but you know in the
word history there's another word what's
the word that's inside history yeah
that's all history is it's a story and I
just try to find a way to tell a story
that would be number one accurate
so there's everything in the book that
would be working on would be true and
second interesting so that you can read
it as a story so that's pretty much what
I do to try to write about history ill
how was that spy from America caught by
the British oh okay bye hi it's a good
question Nathan Hale was a schoolteacher
in Connecticut he went to join the
American army at the beginning of the
revolution and when one of his officers
said we've got to spend we have to send
a spy to where the British are the
British were in New York City and outs
just outside New York City and the
Americans were on the other side of Long
Island Sound if you look at a map you
can think of where New England is where
Connecticut is they were they would row
boats or sail boats across and get into
British lines the British were going
from one they control the area from New
York all the way into most most of Long
Island so Nathan Hale volunteered to go
into New York and find out how many
British troops there were how happy were
there how were how we're supplies coming
to them maybe even get an idea of what
kind of guns they had the big guns
everybody had a gun he carrying but
these would be the cannon and so he
volunteered to do it an interesting
thing about that time is another soldier
another American soldier said at that
time I don't want to be a spy it's just
not right to be a spy I will be a
soldier and I'll risk my life is a
soldier I don't want to be a spy but
Nathan Hale said okay I'll be a spy so
Nathan Hale um had disguised himself not
really disguised too much but he was a
teacher
and he one thing he did he had silver
buckles on his shoes people didn't have
shoelaces at much then and so he took
the silver buckles off that was because
he thought maybe he'd be less to be less
chance of his being seen as a rich man
maybe he goes on lands in Long Island
and for a long time we didn't know quite
what happened how was he caught why was
he caught but in this book it's for the
first time tells how he may have been
caught and here's how I found it out at
the time of the revolution the people
who didn't support the revolution now if
you can think of a hundred people let's
say there were 100 people living in 1776
in the United States of those hundred
people how many do you think were for
the revolution and how many were against
the revolution yeah maybe about 45 like
thanks against and then maybe the rest
yeah that's about right I the historians
figure that about one-third of the
population supported it one third
absolutely we're against it and many of
them lived in New York which was
occupied by by the British through the
entire war and one-third didn't care
either way the ones who supported the
British were called Tories and it's a
word that came out of British politics
it meant somebody basically who
supported the king and as you know the
king we were really in a sense fighting
the king of England when we were
fighting for independence so it was a
Tory a man living in Connecticut who
wrote a history of the Revolution and he
was in what they called house arrest you
know what that means any idea
it means you're holdin your house right
they said well we're not going to put
you in jail but you have to stay in your
house we don't want you doing any work
for the British so in his house he
started writing a history of the
revolution and he finished it Revolution
ended and his family said well it's a
very nice book but we can't publish it
now it's a little dangerous so then his
fan so then his grand kids said well
yeah I grew up and said well maybe we
could publish the manuscript and that
family said well we still don't want to
be known as Tory's well in the year 2000
the manuscript that he had written in
seventeen seventy six seven eight let's
say nine 1778 of 79 that manuscript was
given by his family to the library of
congress in a friend of mine called me
and said hey you know there's a new
manuscript at library of congress and i
talked to somebody at the library of
congress and they had talked to other
historians who specialized in the
Revolutionary War and they thought that
this was an accurate manuscript so I
looked at them what they had to say
about Nathan Hale and they said that
Nathan Hale was caught by a trick there
was a British officer who was going
around trying to get Americans to sign
up to help the British in what we would
call today a special forces unit these
would be a group that could do a quick
radar and then get back on a boat in and
leave so he was going around seaports in
Long Island looking for volunteers for
his special forces group his name was
major Rogers and he sees a man standing
looking a little bit odd and one thing
that spies are told never to do is stand
out ah but there's someone that's
standing out a little bit
and major Rogers is a little suspicious
of them so he goes over to him and you
know what major Roger says I'm an
American spy are you an American spy and
Nathan Hale says yes I am so then major
Roger said well that's interesting you
could be in my group I'm going to bring
in a couple of people from my group and
they go into a tavern or in and they all
sit down and and major Rogers brings in
two British officers who are in civilian
clothes and says these are my two spies
who work for me tell them what you just
told me so Nathan Hale says well I'm
working for the Americans as a spine and
major Roger said okay games over you're
arrested for being a spy and he brought
those two men in so that he would have
witnesses Nathan Hale was tried by a
military court and found to be a spy by
his own admission and was hanged George
Washington tried to get it to be trying
to get it stopped but if there was no
way to do it so he was hanging and
that's the way you got caught according
to one source but that source does seem
to be a pretty reliable one lots of
times you can't get everything to prove
exactly what happened three or four or
five hundred years ago or even 20 years
ago so you do your best and and people
who've looked at this manuscript feel
that it's probably accurate so that's
the answer okay
yeah how in spies to George Washington
well it's a good question we don't know
we know some of them ah by name we know
some of them because we know that some
things were done by some people but we
don't know their names and we don't know
exactly how many i mean if i were to
take a guess i would say probably no
more than 50 or 60 in the course of the
whole revolution but i don't know and
one of the interesting things about this
is that they didn't want to be known as
well you know if you're a spy it
wouldnae but you wouldn't want all of us
to know about it at the time right but
now suppose I said well I want you to be
a spy and I'm going to pay you fifty
dollars a week for being spine right and
that happens people spies are paid just
as a soldier would be paid but it's
going to be tough to pay you right so
we're going to have to wait till after
the war after the war some people came
forward and said the United States this
whole new country we have here owes me
some money because here's what I did and
they would write out some description of
the kind of work they did and they would
sign their names and those records will
be kept and I can go and read those
records and see that Enoch Cosby for
instance was a spy there's a man named
John Honeyman in New Jersey and I just
met his I don't know what it would be
great great-great-great-great
great-great nephew recently here's what
happened honeymoon huh neiman seems to
have been hired directly by george
washington and washington says get me
whatever information you can about the
British who were around Trenton New
Jersey so honey minh lived in that area
and he was a butcher he started selling
meat to the British
there were very few vegetarians in the
British Army and so all his neighbors
said hey this guy is working for the
British let's not have anything to do
with him he's a Tory and Honeyman's
family I got into a lot of trouble with
their neighbors ah who got very angry
that this man was working for the
British so they even started making
threats against his wife and children
and they threatened to burn down his
house they were so mad that he was
working for the British George
Washington sent a letter saying don't do
anything to this family he didn't say
why but that stopped anything happening
to the family but meanwhile hymen is is
caught one day by two American soldiers
a Navy puts up a fight and they say
you're a spy we're going to bring you in
right to George Washington so they bring
him in in Washington says I'm going to
I'm going to question him separately you
guys go away i'm just going to talk to
him and he gets the full report from the
spy about the british troops around
trenton and then he washington calls in
a soldier and says take this man and
hold him in the bar and keep him under
lock and key he's a spy we'll put him on
trial tomorrow and then that night
there's a fire in another part of the
camp and all the soldiers go running off
to put over the fire and honey man
escapes the escape was staged so that he
could get out and and be a spy again for
the British I mean against the British
and some of the information he gave
Washington we don't know exactly what he
gave them but Washington crosses the
Delaware River I don't via the famous
picture of Washington standing in the
bell crossing the river and he catches
the the troops there and he gets a
victory and honeymoon probably had a lot
to do with that victory but it's a long
time it's after the war
all of the information about honey moon
comes out and there's a special place
now in New Jersey where his house is and
where his grave is so he's honored but
he's he represents maybe one out of five
or one out of ten of the people who are
really known as men and women who spied
a lot of women spine and one of them was
a Quaker you know Quakers are not
supposed to I have anything to do with
war they're supposed to be peaceful and
she was a spy for the for the Americans
and the one of the stories about her
after the war was that the Quaker said
well you responded just like being a
soldier we we are very much upset that
you would do this but she felt as an
American she had to do it so she she was
the mother of the boy with the button
that had the cloth on it anymore yeah
how long did it take you to go from this
idea of this book Oh from idea to finish
what else um about a year a little over
a year but I'd be doing other things on
the side it's and then you've got to
realize also working for the geograph I
mean I'm independent but I mean the
geographic editor the designer the
artists all the people you eventually I
mean all I do is write a book when they
make it look the way it looks so that
that process takes about four or five
months but in terms of the calendar you
know you sort of start near one and you
get a book at about year too
yeah George Washington act as a spy
himself um that's a good question he he
did something that spies do and he did
this quite often he lied he deceived and
that's part of the game I they call it
fighting with deception for instance
here's one of the things he did he was
going to head south to join the French
and what would become the end of the war
the decisive battle of the war and he
doesn't want the British or watching him
and they're sending spies into his camps
all the time he doesn't want the British
to know that he's heading south so he he
has a a baker start baking a lot of
bread he has campfires built all over
the place so that they so any spy was
coming in and a spy would be there at
night looking at the camp we'd see that
the camp was still there the soldiers
were still there but he had slipped away
he had managed to get the whole camp
going that was one of his things that he
did as it as a deception another time he
he knew that a spy was coming into the
camp from his own counter spying people
and he got his officers together and
said give them a lot of information tell
tell them how many how many men we have
give them information that will make
this spy look like a good spy when he
gets back in reports and then that's by
having given good information you can
then deceive him later so that would be
the kind of trick that Washington would
pull he would another time he wrote a
lot of orders for a maneuver that he was
not had no intention of of carrying out
and made sure that those orders got in
the hands of the British so the British
would read these document
and say boy look at this we've got the
real documents right from Washington and
they were all wrong and that kind of
trickery would be going on book both
sides all the time he always had to be
one step ahead of that kind of a trick
we did the same thing indeed a you know
in the world war two exactly the same
thing we got the Germans think we were
going to land here and we landed here
and it's it's the way things happen
sometimes in war yeah what inspired you
to do your book George Washington
inspire me I think he's won he's
probably I just think he's one of the
the greatest man who ever lived I think
he's certainly so many so many wonderful
things about him I just have always been
an admirer of George Washington and so
many things have been written about him
that simply are not true that it was fun
to go and find out what was true you got
to be careful of reading about George
Washington sometimes that you're not
reading some of the stories that were
made up about him his life itself was
was a great story and you didn't need to
write any fake stories about fake
stories about um George Washington that
he chopped down a cherry tree and set
yeah yeah yeah there's no basis for that
the other one hasn't throwing a silver
dollar across the Potomac River I don't
know guys have seen how wide the Potomac
River is right yeah all right well then
then it was really probably a
Rappahannock River because he lived near
the Rappahannock River and people have
tried to do this and I suppose it can't
be done but the basic thing is if you
were about 15 years old and you had a
silver dollar the last thing in the
world you were going to do is throw it
somewhere so that that story isn't true
either
anyone thank you for calm okay I enjoyed
it all I when I want her up this
question over here but and ask anyone
who wants to have a book signed sure
come on up line a single by your way
another question oh yeah oh ok ok thank
you very much oh thanks i was going nice
thank you oh oh this is my lemon juice i
was going to give you a demonstration I
you brought up Thomas Allen is the
author of shark attacks remember Pearl
Harbor and America from space his latest
George Washington spymaster is published
by National Geographic books on the web
at National Geographic calm / books